it is the world's most watched he says
she said day 21 of the Johnny Depp Amber
Heard trial welcome to Entertainment
Tonight Michelle Turner is off closing
arguments are expected Friday so in this
final week of testimony Amber's team is
pulling out all the stops to cast doubt
on depth
[Music]
based on your analysis what has caused
Mr Depp's career downturn we talked
about the erratic behavior of the
tardiness the drugs and alcohol abuse
jealousy rapid mood changes
poor self-control Amber's experts
hammered away at the actor all day
Johnny was supposed to be called to
testify by the defense today but in a
surprise pivot her team suddenly called
off that plan the reason a source close
to Amber Heard tells E.T calling Depp
back to the stand would be as relevant
to us as a bicycle to a fish everything
Depp has testified up to this point has
been irrelevant to the heart of this
case and there's no reason to believe it
would be any different now
also testifying for Amber orthopedic
surgeon Dr Richard Moore who did not
treat Depp he questioned the actor's
claim that his finger was severed when
Amber threw a vodka bottle at him it
made contact
and shattered everywhere and it looked
like a it looked like Vesuvius this
wound doesn't really appear to be a
sharp glass laceration Dr Moore
testified it appeared to be more of a
crush injury he was cross-examined by
Depp's attorney trial breakout star
Camille Vasquez I think it's important
that they understand that this is the
time for me to ask you questions do you
see that broken vodka bottle in the back
corner near the bottom of the bar
yes do you see the blood drops on the
floor
you can't definitively say what caused
the injury to Mr Duck's fingers yes or
no
no
and there's a new celebrity twist okay
nice to meet you et has confirmed that
Johnny's ex Kate Moss will take the
stand for Depp's team on Wednesday she
will testify live via video link legal
expert Jesse Weber says Amber opened the
door for her testimony because when
Amber Heard was on the stand she made a
reference to Kate Moss and the stairs I
just in my head instantly think of Kate
Moss and the stairs the allegation being
that Johnny Depp threw Kate mossed down
the stairs when the two are in a
relationship so if Johnny Depp calls her
as a rebuttal witness and says that's
not the truth Johnny Depp was great to
me he never physically assaulted me in
any way that's not going to be great for
Amber Heard
and of course you can watch the trial on
et's YouTube channel
[Music]